great to see you at collect Amalia
fintan what was it about playing Avery
Lord she enjoyed in Game of Thrones I
love my horse
his name is spikey and yet Mike he's
actually from Milton Keynes yeah yeah
he's white and he's called spikey and as
cos his manners spiked and he was from
Romania and I think his brother was
called flathead and but I I loved I
didn't ride prior to that and I said I
learned to ride I said I'd like to think
I'm real or so that was the best part of
it how did you find that then learning
to ride a terrifying at first I thought
you know games up you know it's over you
know give it up you can't ride it's
finished you know there's going to be
two three million down the drain
tomorrow when you fall off in the middle
of a you know a scene and I stayed on
hit the mark
they say said the line and you know two
weeks later it was kind of reversing the
horse and playing around with them so
that was the most interesting thing some
great actors on it as well and I think
some of the other actors in the first
season I wasn't it I was amazed at the
performances actors are really good well
just you know downright brilliant in
your case no dimensions on the show and
you of course you're working with people
like 12 starts and Maisie Williams what
was it
with those guys amazing is fabulous
such an intuitive talents young you know
uninhibited just amazing Charles very
mercurial he's like he's different with
one character the next character and the
next character you just don't know what
to expect so you're being very kind of
khalsa but we have great bonding
fabulous production design you find
yourself in these caverns that are lists
in a very mysterious way you try to
figure the light out you know going
Charles I can't see you you're in the
dark it's alright I can see you Benton
you know I'm just amazed by the
production design and just being in this
other world I mean what did you think
about your own death by poisoned dogs
cheap trick it should have been the bear
in the book it's a bear yeah but I would
have liked to taken on the bear I think
I would have given the bear a really
good you know it would have been me thus
as the bear
it would've been a different ending that
in the book is all all today yeah I
could have dragged the bear through the
village or something you know
now we spoke to Joe Dempsie he obviously
Marie look she's looking out for Gendry
earlier in the year and he said he
misses you from the show because he
loved your line I'm looking for a
bastard named Gendry he's gonna miss you
saying that again so can you say it for
us and Joe today I'm looking for a
bastard named Gendry
you could bring anyone back apart from a
Marie who would you bring back to life
on the show
I got no you see this is the thing who
would she bring back and well yeah but
would you bring really wants to bring
anybody back you know because one of the
hallmarks of the series is that it's
just people just suddenly abruptly die
and that's so true to life isn't it that
in many ways that you know when you die
its abrupt and you're not expecting it
and it's sudden and it's all over and so
that's kind of an intrinsic truth about
the whole kind of nature of power but
when that happens and it's gone it's not
what you anticipate it's not what how
you envisioned it it's just suddenly
over done so I just leave it as it is I
think that's one of the things about
even though it's fantasy genre it feels
very plausible listen - yeah it is
I mean it's inherently there's a
palpable sense of sort of brutal reality
we look forward to seeing you in no
expensive tonight I'm like in Atlantis
but like blinkin you know he missed me
supposedly I returned at a later stage
but I have a scene with mark Addie yeah
at the the front of the show and it was
almost like Game of Thrones we were kind
of in that cabin it was all very dark
ever having this very insinuating
conversation
possible threats to one another I'm
looking forward seen I've done this
thing called the Bible which is like
Game of Thrones meets the Bible and it's
the most seen most watched miniseries of
all time
I know it's a it's a phenomenon I think
150 million people have seen it in
America and hasn't been released here
yet yeah he's in it from Game of Thrones
and some Francis Francis Francis McGee
plegh Yaron was it Francis
so this viewed Game of Thrones actors in
it I mean it's an epic story probably
the greatest story ever told but in many
ways it's it's quite primitive and it's
quite stripped down because it's you
know it's set in that terrain and that
landscape where everything is raw on and
you know uninhibited in many ways just
sort of primitive really in a way
I look forward to seeing that and
avoiding you Atlantis tonight thanks so
much for talking to us winters with
levees is Beach
you